and my light is one of the fastest
growing business personalities who has
also ranked in the top
50 wealthiest under 50 by forbes he went
from being born into a middle-class
family becoming broke and having to
shower at a public pool
to being worth over 400 million dollars
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe nation
top 10.
all my life
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best ed mylett and
my take on his top 10 rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one look for
joy in small things my
lows of bliss and happiness and joy are
much higher than they've ever been in my
life
but i know the highs could be higher and
more consistent
and it's just finding joy in small
things
and when you're a big achiever you have
to be very careful that you only link
your bliss and happiness to
big things and the truth is it's the
most it's like right now being with you
like right when i saw your face like it
just
it brings me joy simple things are
actually ironic or what bring me the
most happiness and the most joy
rule number two be completely immersed
when you really get after something
listen to me total immersion in
something you can become
unbelievably proficient at it that guy
who's thinking about quitting he's not
totally immersed
he's not totally in let me give you an
example real quick my dad's got cancer
you know that
grant knows it my dad has something
called liposarcoma i think dad's okay
with me saying that now
three years ago if you said the word
liposarcoma to me i have no clue what
the hell that means
i'm not an oncologist i know nothing
about cancer right
all of a sudden it became important to
me i became completely immersed in the
topic
of liposarcoma i know what causes it
what treats it
what you die from it how it doesn't grow
you name it right i'm not a cancer
doctor but i know a ton
about that topic because it became so
freaking important to me
if you really want to win you'll get
unbelievable
getting people to believe you believe it
you will be loaded with certainty from
product knowledge
to belief to skills and you will be
completely immersed with
i believe no b plan no other plan
no nothing out completely immersed in it
aside from dunking a basketball or
hitting 100 mile an hour fastball
these are things that are limitations to
human beings but
average ordinary people every single day
succeed in the business of persuading
people there is no limitation to being
able to do it except those things
rule number three have humility first
off knowledge isn't power
it's potential power and it's only
powerful when it's applied as you've
said
i actually think the separator for
people who apply and don't apply is ego
i really think i don't know everything i
really do want to learn i do have a
level of humility about most things that
i'm a student
all the time and when i look at a guy
like you and i was listening to all the
things you're talking about in your
career and how aware you are frankly how
candid you're about things you wish you
did differently
it takes a ton of humility and so i
think if you're not applying things you
need to look at yourself and decide
whether your ego's involved
you'd say well no i'm just afraid ego is
fear
ego applies itself in lots of different
ways but probably the fact that you're
not applying what you're learning is ego
related in some way
rule number four help other people you
can't be happy if you don't love
yourself
and you can't love yourself if you're
not being yourself if you can begin to
live in congruence with your values your
beliefs
and find a way to serve other people
that's always a pathway to your own
bliss to your own happiness and that's
one thing i've seen
i've watched your videos and follow you
and you say the same thing
that you are living you're giving back
you have a purpose and you're giving
back to others and that fulfills you
yeah for me i figured it out a little
bit later in life i used to think well i
want to be rich or
and i do there's i think i think having
material things to some extent can give
you temporary happiness
and certainly be able to feed your
family and provide education for your
family
that's a that's an important thing but i
found out finally in my life you know
what really gives me joy
gives me joy is to is to help other
people is to serve other people
one thing i think that's not said enough
in the world and i since we only have a
little bit of time is
i want everyone to understand this you
were born to do something great with
your life
you were every single human being was
born to do something special with their
lives
and the two best days of your life is
the day you're born and the day you
figure out why
and when you figure that out and always
it'll be a pathway if you listen this
you want to be happier begin to think
about some of your natural gifts things
that you're good at that you enjoy doing
how could you use those in the service
of other people i promise you that's the
pathway
to you being a happier person i love the
book by my brother evan carmichael built
to serve you guys this is the kind of
thing you get in this book
most people wake up and drive to a job
they hate think about your five closest
friends
are they happy do they live their lives
with purpose do you
we put on a fake front for what we want
people to see and think about us
but the reality is most people aren't
happy we're lost we settle
you can't be happy if you don't know
your purpose and then he goes on to
explain how to do that
you guys should get this book built to
serve by my dear friend evan carmichael
rule number five acknowledge your
patterns
i think i had a lot of beat up i mean
emotional mental psychological beat up
i was like beating myself to death
psychologically
for decades of my life those are and
that one thing brother because i know
you've written so eloquently about this
for everybody
that started with you acknowledging and
realizing a pattern
yeah so we have these patterns of
behavior right and so
when you acknowledge a pattern you have
that does not serve you
it loses a lot of its power over you
just by you
seeing it being aware of it like for
example in business for me
usually when i'm doing well there's this
really intense version of me
i don't always like that guy but man
does he produce a lot of results he gets
him saying he gets paid he gets rid of
and and i'm back sort of in the hunt in
a lot of my business in such a way and
that guy's sort of re-emerging
and i've asked my and there's this part
of all of us that think
this that's why i'm successful so
if i took this intensity away or i took
this self-doubt away
or i took this anxiety away i'll lose my
mechanism to achieve we all think this
it's complete bs
or if i take this away i'll lose the
opportunity for girls to want me or have
sex with women or to lose the weight or
to do this
if i take this away right we think
that's part of our secret recipe
when in fact brother and you've realized
this too you're in a more blissful
relationship now
that you were succeeding in spite of
those patterns
not because of them what they are is
they become part of your identity
so you think that's why they produce
these results but you're winning
instead of them in spite of them and so
for me just when they rear their head
i'm like i'm doing that stupid pattern
again here i go again
and it loses some of its power over me
and so you're
do you're a million percent right and
that's why i
i feel so such optimism about my life is
because
i know i kind of know me so i know what
i'm doing that guy here he goes the
worry in me
here he goes the overreacting me you're
doing it again
and it's almost like a clown show when i
do it instead of me going well that's
why i win i mean hey
you may not like that guy but man then
he became a millionaire look at my view
look at my house look at this yeah
and then you use these external things
to validate your own negative pattern
rule number six have certainty i finally
figured out that i'm not trying to
completely convince you everything i'm
saying i'm trying to convince you that i
believe what i'm saying
so i think there's a subtle difference
when you're influencing people people
think to close you i have to convince
you to believe everything
i'm saying i don't believe that's true i
think i have to convince you that i
believe what i'm saying
that's a totally different level of
influence it looks less like a beggar
it looks far more certain which is level
two level two is the more certain person
will always influence the least certain
person
and you know your product so you should
be more certain about it than they are
or your program so
a couple things about that all kinds of
things give you certainty
okay number one preparation knowing your
script
knowing your knowing your product back
and forth believing in your product back
and forth knowing that you know the
words knowing you know what you're going
to say when they
it's a dance this is very interesting to
me when people struggle with sales
there's only like a certain amount of
objections you're going to get and
whatever your industry is you ought to
you already know what they're going to
say it's one of 10 or 20 or 30 or 40
different things
you ought to be ready to respond to them
so most people in sales are professional
presenters they're not professional
closers
so i they're great at their presentation
they can't close
and so i got really good at closing
because someone's going to close
somebody either you're going to close me
you shouldn't or i'm going to close you
that you should
yeah and so the more certain person is
going to win if you just want to accept
that truth
that one you got to believe that i
believe what i'm saying not that you
believe
people buy things all the time and say
yes to things
all the time that they don't necessarily
believe everything about
they believe the person presenting it to
them believes it that's a different
level
rule number seven keep working on
identity
what's something that i guess ed sitting
here right now
could go back and tell the the young ed
what would you uh what would you say hey
you should listen to this one
wow um there's a million things um
because i lack
so much confidence i would have first
told myself hey man you deserve to be
successful
this isn't relegated to people different
than you yeah i think who are these
people that live in these beach houses
and have these
jets or play on tv in a sport they're
like a different species or something
and as i've got to know them all from
doing my show and just from living my
life they're just like you
in many ways they're just human they
have the same emotions the same
weaknesses and whatnot but here's the
deal man
your life you're probably never going to
exceed your identity
and that your identity is the thoughts
and concepts that you believe to hold
really to be true about yourself
and you have multiple identities you
have a happiness one a wealth one a
fitness one a relationship one
and you will never temporarily you could
get a better result than what you
believe you're worth
but you'll find a way to cool it back
down your identity is like that
thermostat on the wall
it sets the temperature for your life so
if you're a 75 degree or let's just say
of wealth
and you live at 75 degrees you might get
it going for a while in business and
you're living at 80 85 degrees
but all of a sudden the thermostat of
your life will kick in unconsciously
and you will find a way to cool it right
back down reverse is true too you start
going broke you can't pay your bills
you'll find a way eventually don't you
didn't starve you didn't get homeless
you heated your life back up to what you
think you're worth yeah and it governs
your life doesn't matter the external
conditions if you have a thermostat in
this room
100 degrees outside it'll still regulate
this room to 75.
yeah and so your identity is a
thermostat of your life
and if you don't change the thoughts
concepts and worth you hold to be true
about yourself
all of the other mechanical things you
do you will find a way
most hall of fame athletes simply have a
higher identity about their craft in
their career most
high performers in fitness high
performers in a relationship
people in faith their faith you see
someone just lives with great faith
they've got 150 degrees of faith
and so they get that no matter what the
conditions are there's a woman on my
show today tony
who was the mother of a five four and
two year old kayla stockline
her husband was a pastor of a church he
hung himself last year in their church
committed suicide and left three
children behind and a loving wife and a
church full of people
and on my show she says that the last
year her faith has only increased and
she's closer to god
how in the world is that possible it's
because no matter what the conditions of
her life
is she's got this gigantic faith
identity so my thing i'd go back and
tell me is you better work on this
identity thing all the time bro you
better keep working on it or you will
find a way to cool your life
back down in every area to what you
think you're worth and what you think
you deserve
rule number eight avoid comparison
comparison is a formula
that's why social media is so dangerous
comparison is a formula for misery
and what we do in our life is we compare
ourselves to the best day and the best
picture on social media that we see of
somebody else
we compare ourselves at different times
in our lives too you know even if you're
in a relationship comparing your
relationship in its fifth year
to its fifth week isn't fair to that
relationship there's different stages in
our life so
comparison is a pathway there's pathways
to happiness and there's pathways
that lead us to unhappiness one of those
for sure is comparison
and it's an ego thing often times with
us we're always trying to one-up things
in our life
it's a matter i think really of being
more present in the moment in your life
and saying
i deserve to be happy right now rule
number nine
negotiate in advance people's will to
win
is easily bought in life and there's
about it's bought two ways he and i have
talked a lot about this he keeps telling
me to write this book but
you got to just ask yourself in advance
here's what people do all the time in
business and life okay
they're constantly negotiating the price
they're paying they're in constant
negotiation in their mind is this worth
it can i go through anymore i don't know
it's so hard they're constantly
negotiating the price this zaps your
energy it zaps your certainty
it zaps everything from you if you're
gonna win negotiate in advance that you
will pay
any price required that you are not for
sale as long as it's legal ethical and
moral
once you've done that when i was poor
i'd walk into stores all the time i
wouldn't buy what i wanted because i was
poor
i'd be flipping price tags over what's
the cost what's the cost what's the cost
i wouldn't get what i wanted i'd get
what i could afford
right i'd negotiate the price okay if
you do that in your life
you will cut you'll eventually be bought
you will either be bought by
failure because it's just too big a
price or worse
this is the one he's talking about
you're bought by some level of success
you get some price tag they give you
your number and they buy your will to
win
and you stop getting after you stop
going to the next level
both are insidious the obvious one is
people who just sell out their will
when they're failing the other one is
for the people in here that oh wow now
you're at 250 grand a year oh wow now
you hit your big number you're at a
million
and your will was bought if you really
size up the really top level at anything
they can't be bought it's like the
heavyweight champion how many guys
it's one thing to win a title i coach a
lot of ufc guys one thing to win a title
totally different deal man to repeat and
repeat again and to repeat again and to
repeat again
and to go win in another weight class
and another weight class
that's a whole different deal it's one
thing to win a super bowl a lot of guys
that want a suit
totally different deal to win five like
brady totally different deal
to win six like jordan right totally
different deal
their will to win could not be bought by
the losses
or the wins this is the separator from
the best at anything
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is embrace the suffering and sacrifice
i want you to write this down i need to
embrace the suffering
you know there's something powerful that
once you just sort of embrace the fact
that in order to achieve something big
you've got to get rid of these
distractions
and then the other layer of it is you're
probably going to have to have some
suffering to get there or some sacrifice
to get there and so once you've embraced
and decided that
this suffering this sacrifice you're
making is an
indicator of progress it's an indicator
of obsession
suffering and sacrifice and hard work
is an indication of progress towards our
dreams
the lack of sacrifice the lack of
suffering in our lives it's removal it's
non-existence
also equates to a non-existence of a
great life a non-existence of a dream
happening a big one anyway
and so embrace the fact that you're
gonna have to sacrifice and suffer to
some extent
once you've embraced that it's going to
happen it's almost not that bad it's
kind of like those of you that are fit
we already know and you already know
even if you're not you've sort of
accepted that before you go to the gym
and get there you're gonna have to
suffer
and we go anyway it becomes a habit no
one goes into a gym
thinking i'm not gonna have to sacrifice
or suffer there'll be no discomfort or
no pain
but millions of people go anyway don't
they to the gym on some level they're
suffering in the gym whether it's
breathing heavy or sweating or aches or
pains or stress you know everything in
the gym is a sacrifice and to some
extent
you're suffering going through some pain
you know it before you go don't you
yet most of us go all the time yet in
life
outside of that one area most of us
are worried about suffering we're afraid
of it when we're suffering and
sacrificing we wonder whether it's worth
it we wonder whether we're supposed to
we wonder whether sacrifice
or setbacks or suffering is a sign it's
not our real dream
don't we see at the gym you never think
oh i'm going through some pain and
discomfort this must be a sign i
shouldn't be at the gym you'd never
think that
it goes with the territory everyone
knows this build a bicep or a tricep or
a chest or legs
you have to break it down suffer and
sacrifice for it to grow
so while it's happening there's no part
of you that says this isn't
right in fact the indication of the pain
and sacrifice and sweat
don't you feel better at the gym you're
like wow i really sacrificed today
i really suffered so in that area we all
know to the extent we suffer and
sacrifices to the extent we grow
and your body is a metaphor for the rest
of your life but the rest of our life
every time we sweat
every time we sacrifice every time we
suffer we don't do what we do at the gym
we start saying well wait a minute
maybe i'm not supposed to be doing this
maybe i'm not cut out maybe it's not my
destiny
maybe i just can't do it now i've got a
really special bonus clip that i think
you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
wanna know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated
but never created a plan and when you
share your plan and have accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through
so in the comments below write down your
single biggest takeaway as well as your
specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
you're this all the time your life's
going to be the five people but it's
be have specificity with your
associations like if you want to be a
richer person you must begin to find
seek out a group of people around you
who are more successful financially than
you
and if i'm 100 degree or financially and
you're a 75 degree
through proximity over time i get you to
85 or 90 degrees
proximity equals power so in fitness too
if you're 35 pounds overweight and
everybody you're hanging out with
eats greens and clean all the time and
trains five days a week
you'll over time change your fitness
identity if you have a very low
threshold of faith you kind of believe
but it's
ebb and flow and the five people around
you most of the time are these strong
believers and whatever their faith is
they heat you up somewhere in between
your identity and theirs
so what i do is i'm constantly
aggressively
seeking out new associations to add to
my life and trying to get them closer to
me
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this
channel i have a dedicated brand new
channel just for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there
you